enjoy a typical night in New York City
this is Pauline Kersey this is the story
of a person who decided to clean up the
most bigoted city in the world but you
think you're some kind of tough guy huh
a real big man yeah too bad that's just
a social construct false archetype
perpetuated by Western civilization scum
did you get yourself in it
okay exchange yes you're gonna need it
some call him a hate crime vigilante
some call him a hero some call him Z a
new white privilige puke century no is
that any way to treat a training you
know the best part of my friend here mr.
Walter when it comes to targets is
gender neutral Deathwish 14 the
reassignment hey did you like this video
it what you didn't oh you're a cat
person well that makes sense
disregard him and or her /z everyone
else hit the subscribe button and leave
your comment below as to why you like
this video I you know what crazy cat you
can get back you couldn't you can
comment below to as to why you don't
like it